all right let me give you some more
details of the main moves in that
reshuffle by Richie soon now Jeremy Hunt
will remain in post as Chancellor of the
exchequer Dominic Robb returns to his
role as Deputy Prime Minister he's also
been appointed to Lord Chancellor and
Justice secretary role that he held
before as well that means that Brandon
Lewis is now gone as Justice secretary
and James cleverley has retained his
role as the foreign secretary swella
Braverman who resigned six days ago for
breaking the ministerial code has been
reappointed as Home Secretary Ben
Wallace remains imposed as the defense
secretary Steve Barkley returns to being
a Home Secretary a health secretary
sorry a role that he left in September
he replaces Therese coffee who will be
moving to defra where she becomes the
environment secretary
Grant chaps has been appointed at
business secretary replacing Jacob Reese
mogg who conceded he would not get a job
in Richardson United's cabinet despite
recanting his claim from the summer the
the new prime minister was a socialist
Jillian Keegan the MP for Chichester has
been appointed Secretary of State for
Education replacing kit malthouse who
moves on back to the back Ventures
Michelle Donovan has been reappointed as
Secretary of State for digital culture
media and Sport Michael Gove is back in
government reappointed and Secretary of
State for leveling up after being sacked
by Boris Johnson back in July Mel stride
Rishi sunax leadership campaign manager
who's been appointed the work and
pensions secretary replacing Chloe Smith
has retained her position within cabinet
as International Trade secretary Simon
harp is the new Chief whip replacing
Wendy Morton who's gone she presided
over the chaotic vote last week on
fracking Nadeem sahawi has been
appointed as party chairman and Minister
without portfolio meaning that Jake
Berry has moved on from that role and
it's Oliver Darden who'll take over
Nadeem zahawi's formal role as
Chancellor of the duchy of Lancaster
he's also been appointed as cabinet
office minister
now Penny Morton Who challenged with
sunak for the leadership has been
reappointed as Lord president of the
council and leader of the House of
Commons
Chris Heaton Harris has been reappointed
as Secretary of State for Northern
Ireland
as to Jack is back as Secretary of State
for Scotland and David TC Davies has
been appointed as the new secretary of
state for Wales he replaces Robert
Buckland